okay alright let's talk about the wars
because so much happen with Isis and I
know you follow Isis very closely hey
you've been okay attention I don't
follow Isis I know you selfish you know
a lot of love me love it a lot of
developments about Isis and I want to
get everybody's take on this it see what
the significance okay one Isis is now in
Libya we found out that they took over a
whole town including beheadings gender
separation all the stuff that make them
so fun in Syria al Qaeda and Isis have
patched up their feud and they're back
together great uh Isis would be
jihadists are getting on cruise ships to
get to the battlefield because they're
not apparently inspected you know they
shouldn't eat the food on those cruise
ships maybe they should do that's
our fellowman the joint you head of the
Joint Chiefs said it would take eighty
thousand troops on the ground to retake
all the territory if we wanted to
actually defeat Isis so I guess my first
question is shouldn't we stop all this
talk about we're gonna militarily defeat
Isis cuz it would involve troops on the
ground and we're not gonna do that
you know what's never discussed when we
talk about Isis is the fact that
probably their most powerful military
forces within that are operating under
the banner of Isis are secular former
Baathists that were fired by George
Bush's brilliant man Paul Bremer in Iraq
they've joined a coalition with radical
Islamist who are doing the kinds of
things you're talking about they're
beheading people they're imposing a very
insane interpretation of Sharia law but
this is not just you know crazy Muslims
who want to behead people there are
people in the north of Iraq that are
fighting the same war that they were
fighting against Bush's troops when he
got sent in so to narrow it down to this
would be like saying Bush was on a crown
on a religious crusade going into Iraq
and he hired Blackwater the neo
Crusaders and they went in there and
they started waterboarding people and
ripping out their and this is a
Christian war I think it's much more
complicated then oftentimes we write it
off as well just this is just the
religion it is a much more complex
landscape right now but
look my at my age of view of this is
that once upon a time in American
presidents can have the spine to say
we're not going to do anything it's
actually their problem and and at some
point I agree some point the regional
powers if it really is a big problem
then Turkey should be tackling its how
do you now we can help them and we could
definitely support them but why are we
the ones it's like welfare why are we
the ones that have to go in their own it
and that's why they're they're doing
well the best thing the ice has ever
happened Isis is Obama elevating them to
this grand global brand
that's why I'll tighten Isis today I
don't end in defense of the president I
don't think he decided that Isis is our
number one public enemy I think there's
there's critical intelligence that
indicates look if the police
commissioner of New York City Bill
Bratton who used to be the police
commissioner here in Los Angeles I'm boy
you said publicly that Isis is the
number one threat in New York City why
because they are so sophisticated with
their social media and with with
recruiting lone Wolf's over the Internet
they have massive video showing you know
folks in the inside the US until we made
it our war they were interested in
taking back they will rock this for
anybody
your national your social media talk
about the intelligence of course they
won't run when I'm to the Khorasan group
remember when they were the big threat
then they disappear now it's Isis then
go back to it being al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula it's the flavor of the
month of terrorism there's the near term
said there were 5,000 Islamic militant
groups in the world 5,000 um it's a
little disingenuous to say that there
are that many Islamic militant groups in
the world there are some of them they're
better funded there are some of them
that have our better Network there some
of them have more territory
Isis has all of those things it's a size
of the state of Indiana it's got massive
financial resources I mean this is not
just don't it's way more powerful than
al Qaeda was when we were hit at home
and I know but here's the thing
I'm detective point I think unless we
let the Muslims have this fight amongst
themselves it's never gonna work out the
right way cuz as long as we're doing the
fight it doesn't have enough credit
it's like when I were you or I say
critical things about Islam its
nearly as effective as when an Islamic
person a Muslim says something critical
it has to come within it from within the
tribe even though we're saying the exact
same thing right and and either the
Iraqis want their country together or
they don't and apparently they don't and
until they fight blood aliy enough to
realize it's not worth it
there's nothing we can do but I don't
know that's it we have matter we'll say
make it work without without bringing up
the context I mean Saudi Arabia one of
the u.s. top allies is beheading people
sheriff Dan right atrocious human rights
record right here we are now in bed with
general Sisi and Egypt who is Mubarak
after New York we we have bear a big
this isn't just oh muslim zine to fight
muslims the u.s. is not a passive player
in this the u.s. is funding the very
threat that we get to be try to become a
passive player that's what we're saying
all right